dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here
do you remember star transfer star
transfer is a mostly AI B's technique
where we take a photograph put a
painting next to it and it applies the
style of the painting to our photo that
was amazing also do you remember pose
estimation this is a problem where we
have a photograph or a video of someone
and the output is a skeleton that shows
the current posture of this person so
how about something that combines the
power of pose estimation with the
expressiveness of star transfer for
instance this way we could take a video
of a professional dancer then record a
video of our own let's say moderately
beautiful moves and then transfer the
dancers performance onto our own body in
the video let's call it motion transfer
have a look at these results how cool is
that
as you see these output videos are quite
smooth and this is not by accident it
doesn't just come out like that
with this technique temporal coherence
is taken into consideration this means
that the algorithm knows what it has
done a moment ago and will not do
something widely different making these
dance motions smooth and believable this
method uses a generative adversarial
Network where we have a neural network
for pose estimation or in other words
generating the skeleton from an image
and a generator network to create new
footage when given a test subject and a
new skeleton posture these two neural
networks battle each other and teach
each other to distinguish and create
more and more authentic footage over
time some artifacts are still there but
note that this is among the first papers
on this problem and it is already doing
incredibly well this is fresh and
experimental just the way I like it
to follow up papers down the line and
will be worried that we can barely tell
the difference from authentic footage
make sure to have a look at the paper
where you will see how the pics to pix
algorithm was also used for image
generation and there is a nice
evaluation section as well and now let
the age of AI base dance videos begin if
you enjoyed this episode please consider
supporting us on patreon where you can
pick up really cool perks like early
access to these videos voting on the
order of future episodes and more we are
available at patreon.com slash two
minute papers or just click the link in
the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time